so you're a part of the one percent
great right wrong see you have so much
money coming in that you're gonna have
to pay way too much to the taxman so you
need a way to avoid taxes to show on
paper that you're making a lot less
money because you know you'd rather not
find more stuff like this or this or
maybe even this you have a right to keep
more of the money you rightfully earned
one of the ways to do that is by
starting a charitable foundation now you
may be wondering but jake how does that
make any sense if i put money in a
charity then that money has to go
towards charity and not my own personal
gain calm down calm down i will walk you
through everything see it doesn't matter
who owns your money on paper because the
only thing that really matters is who
has ultimate control of your money so
whether your money is under your name or
under your charities name is irrelevant
as long as you get to control where
those funds go it may not be you
spending it but it's still you spending
it if you know what i mean and with
charities there are many avenues many
ways to go about doing this where you
still get to enjoy all the fruits of
your labor way more than letting it go
to the taxman i'll legally mind you not
legal or financial or tax advice consult
with an attorney financial planner and
cpa and on top of that you get the
benefit of looking like a saint like a
robin hood raising money from the rich
and giving to the poor while keeping the
plebs at bay so they don't pillage you a
sentiment that keeps on brewing
[Music]
so if you want in on the secretive world
i'm gonna show you step by step how to
legally reclaim your money from greedy
uncle sam by starting a charity
[Music]
giving the charity is still incredibly
important selfishly studies have shown
that giving to charity neurologically
makes you feel better and altruistically
there are legitimate people out there
that need your help and legitimate
charities out there that really do care
and do an effective job so if you have a
little money to spare you should give
it's something that i do every month and
one of those legit organizations is
omaze today's video sponsor omaze gives
away one-of-a-kind prizes and
experiences while donating money to
charities all across the world their
approach to fundraising means that
nonprofits can spend less time raising
money and more time doing what they do
best making an actual difference to
their causes like this tesla model s
plaid edition that you can enter for a
chance to win right now if you haven't
seen reviews for the plot already is the
fastest production car in the world
right now at 0 to 60 in just 1.99
seconds with more than a thousand
horsepower and it starts at 130 thousand
dollars donate 10 or more and you're
entered for a chance to win it and yes
taxes and shipping are covered for us
winners while at the same time you get
to support reverb a great cause has
already eliminated over 3 million
single-use plastic bottles along with a
ton of other accomplishments and for
full transparency here's how the numbers
break down as listed on their website
for prices like a car vacation or cash
15 of your donation is guaranteed to go
to the nonprofit and around 65 to 75 is
used to pay for expenses like the actual
price marketing like this video etc
leaving omaze with a 10 to 20 profit
margin now 15 going to a nonprofit may
not sound like much but 15 of 1 million
is a lot more than ninety percent of ten
thousand dollars that a non-profit may
raise on their own because they're
usually not experts on marketing so to
potentially win this tesla model s and
support a great cause go to omaze.com
jake tran with the link below
[Music]
in 2014 the ceo of gopro nicholas
woodman had just taken the company
public and was all of a sudden worth 3
billion dollars so he announced one of
the biggest acts of generosity in
billionaire history he was giving away
500 million dollars of gopro stock to
charity every news channel praised him
as what they called one of america's
most generous donors and putting him up
there with people like bill gates and
michael bloomberg but years later
there's still no record of the women
foundation or the 500 million dollars
the foundation doesn't even have a
website it doesn't have any areas of
focus listed and there's no trace of any
grants made to non-profits public
records turn up just one beneficiary a
benefit event for an elementary school
in california so where did the money go
and who actually benefited from the
money he donated he did obviously
woodman made his donation public right
after gopro went public see if he didn't
donate he would have owed taxes on the
500 million dollars worth of stock
but by donating wouldn't avoid paying
taxes on the 500 million worth of stock
and claimed a charitable tax deduction
that would reduce his taxes for years to
come and the charities he was supposedly
going to donate to we don't know because
the widowman foundation actually exists
as an account within the silicon valley
community foundation which isn't
required to disclose how if at all he
spends his charitable dollars
he was gonna have to pay tens of
millions of dollars in taxes anyways so
simply by giving away while still
maintaining discreet control over 500
million dollars worth of stock he saved
himself on that giant tax bill while at
the same time he got national
recognition in the press for his
generosity and now he's free to spend
the money as he pleases he can donate to
charities that maybe he controls that
maybe his friends or family control all
speculation of course because it's all
privates and if you want to do the same
it all starts with step number one
starting your own charity
[Music]
the type of charitable vehicle our
friend women use is called a death dafts
or donor advised funds are basically a
charitable savings account used by the
rich and powerful like mark zuckerberg
paul allen the founders of whatsapp to
control where their money goes and when
let's say you receive a giant payout
this year which comes with an equally
giant tax bill so you put 10 million
dollars in a death today when you most
need the tax advantage you write off
that 10 million immediately while not
actually having to donate that money to
charities until 5 years from now 10
years from now or maybe even
indefinitely and how do you donate that
money well maybe your kid is desperately
trying to get into a university so out
of the goodness of your heart with no
strings attached you make a generous
donation to that university for the good
of the students of course maybe you need
a favor from an influential person that
reason non-profits so you sign a giant
check to them again no strings attached
many possibilities to play around with
another great thing about deaths you can
give that money to whatever charity you
like without them needing to report who
they got it from so dafs are basically a
charity savings account that is a very
powerful tool to influence the world to
work in your favor while maintaining
complete anonymity and saving you taxes
the other great option is starting a
family or private foundation outside of
being able to control what your
foundation spends your donations on
donations to private or family
foundations let you deduct whatever you
donate and you can donate not just cash
but assets like shares real estate cars
houses yachts and not pay capital gains
tax on all those assets which allows you
to grow your donations in an almost
tax-free environment for you and your
kids to use for almost however you
please plus with all that money you're
donating you can employ your own family
members or friends pay them very
generous salaries and finance charitable
yet fun expenses like parties galas art
exhibits or whatever flow to your yachts
things that you would have already spent
money on you could even make loans to
businesses get repaid in interest and
use that money to continue living it up
with your friends if you decide that the
daf savings account thing is for you
it's as simple as opening up an account
and putting money into it but if you
want to go all out and open up a family
or private foundation then the fun is
just getting started first you gotta
develop your mission and vision make it
really believable in a real tear jerker
go for world peace or an end to world
hunger really tug at the heartstrings
choose a name preferably without your
name in it pretentiousness is not really
the look you're going for here although
for myself i would probably still go
with the tran foundation of course
register your foundation learn from
nicholas woodman's mistake and actually
launch a website add some compassionate
photos buzzwords like inclusiveness
establish an advisory board and fill it
with your friends and family members you
know the people you already collab with
and now that your charity is set up it's
time to fund it
step 2 donate to your own charity like
we talked about this entire video
donating to your own charity is a great
way to put money to work that would have
otherwise gone to the taxman anyways now
donating to your own charity sounds kind
of weird but it's entirely legal because
technically charitable foundations have
no owners and as long as your funds are
used for charitable purposes which we'll
go over later wink wink you're in the
clear you get that tax deduction and you
can even give up to 60 of your income
away without having to pay taxes on it
so you move your money from your income
pocket to your charity pocket
once you've funded your charity with
your own money why stop there why not
get other donors involved so you have
even more charitable dollars to play
around with
donors are the lifeblood of your charity
there are really two types of donors
you'll deal with number one are actual
random people you attract through your
marketing to get them to donate real
people that you convince your
fundraising events storytelling sad
pictures and videos that your cause is
not only worth supporting but that your
organization is the best at supporting
that cause the second type of donors you
deal with are your friends family and
the people you do business with people
that you can offer some sort of benefit
to them in exchange for donating to your
foundation whether that be favors
partying together at charitable events
you host etc but at some point in this
process you're gonna need help running
your foundation it's really hard work
after all so it's time to bring on some
help
step number four hire your friends and
family and pay them a hefty salary
private or family foundations let you
hire friends and family as staff as long
as they have the skills to do the job
and are paid a reasonable salary but
reasonable is such a broad term and
having the right skills is also such a
broad term see you as a rich person were
probably already gonna give money to
your parents your siblings your in-laws
anyways giving back to your family was
probably one of the main motivations for
you to get rich in the first place so if
you're gonna give money away to these
people why not kill two birds with one
stone and make the money you give them
tax deductible or have it not come out
of your pocket at all in the case of
having other donors and plus the people
you hire receive some nice experience to
put on their resume as well this is the
kind of out of the box thinking you need
to have in this world and this is also
again not legal or tax advice or any
advice for that matter don't do anything
i say in this video and if your friends
become foundation managers they not only
get a fat paycheck they can also join
you in all the luxury trips parties and
events you host for the charities
benefit at the charities expense so now
that you've taken care of your friends
you staffed and developed your charity
now it is time to read the benefits
step number five spend your charitable
dollars lavishly for the cause of course
last year the black lives matter
foundation received more than 90 million
dollars in donations and conveniently
just this year one of the founders of
blm patrice khan cullers bought a 1.4
million dollar house in la now there may
not be proof that donations to the
charity were used to buy the la mansion
but blm finances go through a
complicated network of for-profit and
non-profit causes that make it difficult
to say with certainty where that money
came from and even if it didn't her
position in the charity got her a deal
with warner brothers and enough money to
buy another three houses all while
serving as the leader of the foundation
and she's not alone donald trump
famously bought two portraits of himself
and assigned denver broncos helmet at a
charity auction using money from his
foundation he also donated more than 250
thousand dollars to the central park
conservancy simply because he wanted a
fountain outside his plaza hotel fixed
and in one of the most blatant cases of
self-dealing ever he donated a full
seven dollars to the boy scouts the same
year his son donald trump jr 11 at the
time wanted to join coincidentally seven
dollars was the joining fee he basically
used his charity as a checkbook for
things he wanted and got away with it
for years where he faltered was that he
attracted too much attention when people
finally caught on and shut the charity
down he only had to pay the remaining
2.8 million of funds to charities a
fraction of what he donated and spent
over the years the good news is that you
can do the same thing and you don't have
to think small whether you donate to
political organizations that lobby for
your interests plaster your name on
every university and 100 mile radius for
branding or legacy purposes conveniently
receive favors after writing a giant
check to someone or decide to donate to
the legit charities you support because
at least they're not as wasteful as the
government your choices are endless
and boom you got to make good use of
your money that would have went to the
tax man albeit after jumping through a
few hoops while looking like a saint and
keeping the plebs at bay but as you can
see having a charitable foundation or
death can be so much more and come with
so many other benefits that you can use
in your favor and if you're lucky you'll
be avoiding taxes long after you die
since all the money you bury in your
foundation can bypass the death tax that
means all that money will be sitting
there for your children to use in the
same manner as you did
[Music]
and before we end this video i would
like to take a moment and make a big
announcement the tram foundation is now
an officially registered 501c chair i'm
kidding i'm kidding maybe in the future
[Music]
but in reality there are good charities
out there making a real difference in
helping people i have a few that i
donate to every month and i plan on
sending aside more of my monthly revenue
to donations and not just for the tax
benefits for all the hate rockefeller
gets as a greedy robber baron he made it
a point to give to charity especially
when he had nothing rockefeller got his
first job at age 16 as a bookkeeper at a
brokerage for fresh produce and right
away he started setting his size six
percent of his salary to charity which
was a mere 50 cents per day or around 16
a day in 2021 money now that may not be
that much but can you say the same for
yourself especially your 16 year old
self i know i can't and he would go on
to be one of the most generous men in
history and the richest man of the
modern era as rockefeller shows it's 100
possible to both make a ton of money and
be a lot more generous than the average
man at the same time
as rockefeller said i think it is a
man's duty to make all the money he can
keep all he can and give away all he can
i wasn't corrupt unfair or greedy i was
smart when it came to making decisions
for my company and i wasn't greedy i
gave to others in charity and donated
money to fun programs and i have nothing
else to say
[Music]
so are you gonna start a charity let me
know what you would call your charity in
the comments below and if you like this
video we've been slowly building up a
whole series of scenes on how to avoid
taxes in the most sexy interesting ways
we have one on using fine art we have
another one on tax havens shell
companies all that good stuff although
that one is a little bit outdated with
the tactics and i will link to both in
the description below and if you're
still watching this video and you're not
subscribed what are you doing because we
make video essays just like this one
every single week on the most
provocative stuff in the world of
business just like this video so if you
like this one you will definitely like
the other ones and you can always
dislike unsubscribe and leave me your
best hate comments in the comments below
so you have nothing to lose and
everything to gain for some reason our
instagram is way smaller than this
channel it's at like 14 000 followers so
let's try to get it up to like 50k or
100k i don't know but i do more behind
the scenes stuff than the life kind of
stuff over there so if you're interested
in that stuff you can join me at
jaketrain.io don't forget that you can
donate and be entered for a chance to
win a tesla model s plaid thanks to our
sponsor omaze and if you do win it i
would be very jealous so take me for a
ride or something that would be linked
below but anyways that's gonna wrap it
up for this video thank you so much for
watching you've been awesome i've been
jake stay dangerous out there and i will
see you guys in the next one
[Music]
you